mais il est vachement bien le film alors
tu me dis au revoir et j'y vais j'ai
plus envie
Mathilde Seigner donc vous êtes ici
aussi pour la sortie du film danse avec
lui réalisé par Valérie Guignabodet à
qui on doit marriage excellent film dans
celui-ci il y a Sami frais c'est un film
important pour votre carrière vous dites
ce film a libéré quelque chose dans mon
cerveau ce n'est pas par hasard si
depuis j'ai rencontré quelqu'un et que
j'attends un enfant oui non c'est un
film important bien sûr un tournant et
un film important c'est pas forcément
pour ça que j'ai rencontré
mon amoureux et j'ai un enfant mais
c'est vrai que ça m'a libéré de plein de
choses dans ma tête voilà le film sort
le 21 février et l'enfant
21 février
[Applaudissements]
spéciale pour l'enfant
du film danse avec lui mon homme j'ai
plus envie de la faire
non mais du coup j'ai pas envie pourquoi
moi j'avais dit hier je viens mais il
faut que je parte tôt sinon je viens pas
bien le film tu me dis au revoir et j'y
vais j'ai plus envie
comme ça
j'ai après moi je fais je suis intuitif
je suis sincère alors par contre j'étais
contente de venir
mais c'est pour toi j'en ai rien à
[ __ ]
[Musique]
allez dis au revoir et je m'en vais
ça aucune importance je te jure
ma grossesse doit m'apporter un truc
c'est que j'en ai rien à secouer par
contre vraiment tu vois bon
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu